good morning and welcome to Sophie Ridge
on Sunday I'm Trevor Phillips you
probably didn't expect to see me sitting
in for Sophie this morning but surprise
surprise as Cilla Black used to say and
frankly there could be far bigger shops
before the day is out Vladimir Putin
probably didn't expect to wake up on his
birthday weekend to see the bridge he
opened to Crimea with a massive hole in
it what you gonna do about it Liz truss
said she didn't mind being unpopular but
I would suppose even she expected she'd
have to drop one of her Chancellor's
headline tax cuts the abolition of the
45p rate but it looks like she'll now
have to quell a cabinet Rebellion over
where the benefit rise in line with
inflation or earnings would she stand
firm or buckle
care stone is probably rubbing his eyes
in disbelief at an average pole lead of
over 25 percent that would hand him a
stonking majority in a general election
but could the SNP leader Nicholas
sturgeon put a span in the works on that
one
well like all political journalists I
wish I had a crystal ball I don't but in
the next 60 minutes we'll do the next
best thing which is talk to the people
who have to answer those questions
in a moment I'll be joined by one of the
most senior cabinet members cabinet
office Minister Nadim zahari
Plus for labor the shadow workers
pensions secretary Jonathan Ashworth
and just days before the SNP takes its
case for a second Scottish referendum to
the Supreme Court we'll be speaking to
the cabinet secretary for the
Constitution external Affairs and
culture the snp's Angus Robertson
Railways are getting back to normal this
morning but nurses are now balloting for
strike action I'll be speaking to the
RCN General Secretary and chief
executive at Pat Cullen
and our supermarkets offer one pound hot
meals and warm spaces to help people
cope with Rising energy bills the former
sainsbury Chief Executive Justin King
joins us
[Music]
and joining me now is the cabinet office
Minister Nadim zahawi good morning well
Minister
now you've written a newspaper article
this morning calling on conservative MPS
to Rally around Liz truss did you expect
that you'd have to be within a month of
her election you'd have to be begging
your colleagues to give her a break
so I wrote the article because I think
uh delay is our biggest enemy we've got
two years to demonstrate to the nation
that we can deliver deliver the growth
plan deliver the energy strategy that
weans us off expensive oil and gas being
imported to the United Kingdom by
investing in nuclear investing in
offshore wind onshore wind and of course
other Renewables
and I want my colleagues to obviously
Focus because
any uh dither or delay will end in
defeat and that's what we don't want to
see we want to be able to demonstrate to
the nation as we have done first couple
of days in office Liz truss put on and I
was translated exchecker who developed
the plans the biggest energy package to
protect households and businesses
probably in history is an enormous
intervention to make sure the households
can feel safe at Christmas that they'll
have the ability to keep the heating on
whilst Putin are you put in your in your
opening
remarks is using energy as a weapon
against us because of the help we're
putting into Ukraine and to get Ukraine
uh their country back so I understand
that but the thing that you really most
apparently I read the article want to
delay is torium peace criticizing the
Prime Minister did you expect that you'd
have to do that well I want to see Unity
I want us to now that we've had a
leadership election we've got a prime
minister in place we've got 24 months to
deliver the cabinet office is
effectively I'm the Chief Operating
Officer of the government the CEO my
responsibility
um Liz has given us the priorities for
each department so let me bring that to
life for you in health it's about a b c
d so ambulance the backlog
care than GPS and dentists doctors and
dentists if we deliver that in the next
two years where people feel confident
they'll get their GPA appointment within
two weeks hopefully even earlier they'll
get a dentist appointment on the NHS
that we will actually finally deliver a
care system that is fit for purpose that
people can see and feel the difference
then we will we will absolutely I think
be confident going to the country and
saying give us another term I want to
give you a chance to talk about policy
in a second but let's just deal with the
politics
um you're not the only ones taken to
newspapers this morning um Penny mordant
and trailer Braverman your cabinet
colleagues have written similar pieces
um could this be the same Penny mordant
who was the first to publicly disagree
with the uh policy of let's wait and see
on inflation or earnings benefits or
could it be the same scholar bravaman
who told a fringe meeting second day of
your conference that she thought the
u-turn on 45p was disappointing uh I
have to say isn't this a bit like the
arsonists turning up uh to a house fire
with a with a bucket saying oh we want
to help they're the ones who started
this well first of all you will know
true because you've been to you're a
veteran of party conferences party
conferences there's a way of telling me
I'm old no you're gonna put me off they
offered this well
first of all as I said we'd been in
office
um under Liz truss uh for a very short
period of time when uh her late Majesty
sadly passed away and then we had to
obviously coordinate and it was the
honor of my life to coordinate um the
funeral and commemoration for her
majesty
um and of course we have cabinet
Collective responsibility but we've
literally had anything only one cabinet
meeting that hasn't stopped us doing the
work we I have as in my role as Chief
Operating Officer been making sure all
those targets
um are now unpacked there's
um
targets by by time and of course
um by milestone in place for each of
those ministers you're not dealing with
this man which is about your colleagues
yes who were the first to criticize uh
the chancellor and the prime minister in
various ways suddenly deciding that
they're calling for Unity I mean for
goodness sake well so let's just be
seriously no it is very serious because
actually both Penny and swella are part
of that Team part of that cabinet is
we've got cabinet Collective
responsibility on the Universal Credit
um uh uplift the Secretary State at the
department for work in patches Chloe
Smith there's a process you know that
there's a process the actual data from
September is still not uh fully uh
collated the one thing I would tell your
viewers is list trust will always be on
the side of helping the most vulnerable
the eight million most vulnerable
households are not only getting the
advantage of the energy price cap she's
putting the average household not paying
more than two two and a half thousand
pounds for their energy but also the
1200 pounds that we'd previously got in
place that we're getting to those
households so we'll always be on the
side of those households that need the
most help but until we have the process
complete at DWP no decision has been
made on the Universal Credit
um uh on the benefits operating but if I
really say so this is this is unusual
for you you're you're still not
answering my question the two cabinet
ministers who have written these
articles knew all that you've just said
when they went out of the Conservative
Party Conference and said oh no we're
not going to stick to the line and wait
uh until the chance was decided on this
benefits thing Penny Morton said and for
inflation uh when she knew that the the
cabinet line was not to say anything
day after U-turn says actually don't
think that was right and they're now
saying calling for Unity this doesn't
make any sense
when you are moving at PACE and delay uh
is um your enemy yeah we have little
time we're 24 months to demonstrate to
the nation that we can deliver this
growth plan
um we can deliver the energy plan we can
deliver the infrastructure the health
care plan all these things
um we're moving you know incredibly if
Penny was here all swell as I said of
course we take cabinet Collective
responsibility on swella's point what
she was saying is this prime minister is
focused on tax take tax receipts coming
into the extract to pay for the doctors
and nurses and teachers and police
officers that we want to see
um actually delivering for this country
that is you know perfect sensible but we
have collect cabinet Collective
responsibility and when we make a
decision on the Universal Credit on the
benefits uplift everybody we will row
behind all right let's let's talk about
policy the uh the Prime Minister
introduced a new phrase to us last week
the ant T growth Coalition now I suppose
that includes people who don't want
building on Green Belt people who don't
want fracking who people who like their
Villages just as they are and don't want
new housing Estates at the bottom of the
garden and people who think that we've
had far too much at immigration and we
shouldn't be doing any more of that um
no sound to me like solid Tory voters so
isn't your strategy self-destructive you
are mischievously conflating consent
other people versus actual policy on
delivery of a of a dynamic economy why
do I say that so let's take the issue of
immigration people absolutely right that
we want to Bear Down on bad migration so
if you look at say let me give you an
example on International students
International students are a A plus a
really positive thing for our
universities for our communities but if
you look at the number of dependents
that come with International students
you'd expect most of his attitudes may
bring one dependent or if they are doing
a PhD they might bring their wife and
maybe a child or two there are some uh
people who are coming to study in the UK
who are bringing five six more people
with them is that right no because we
have to make sure that they actually
they're coming to legitimately study
here uh and of course that is the right
thing to do to look at bearing down on
um abuse of the system
on the the other side of of that
equation uh on the projects that we're
trying to deliver so let's look at
gigabit Broadband we need more uh
Engineers who can splice the actual
um uh uh technology together to deliver
Brigade Broadband if we need another two
or three hundred Engineers to come in to
be able to do that at PACE I think
people will support that if you look at
what we're doing on um what we're doing
on investment zones investment zones are
about local areas consenting to having
an investment zone that includes your
substantial amounts of Residential
Building of commercial building that's a
good thing on this is on tapping into
our gas assets okay just before you go
on to that right uh this is a great
picture you're painting yeah when you
say people who will support that I take
one person who's not going to support it
soiler Brevin who last week said we want
to get immigration down to net below net
100 000. right now it's net 239
000. she is one person who is not going
to agree with the words you've just said
honestly I'm gonna I'll answer that in a
very straightforward way because I have
a weekly meeting
um because I chair that meeting
um on both uh legal migration and of
course the illegal migration that we
want to stamp out um including the issue
around you know the small boats where
people are being
um you know having their lives put in
danger by these gangs we want to break
that business model with swella bravaman
in those weekly meetings because again
remember what I said to you at the
beginning time is against us delay is
our enemy we have to move at PACE to
deliver the stuff as the Chief Operating
Officer I do that as well as in those
meetings every week and she would agree
with me when I say to you we have to
bear down on the bad migration and make
sure that the economy and the big
projects I want to deliver the uh the
needs of those projects are met at speed
in the next 24 months because what Liz
wants to see is not just announcements
but delivery
when we next see her we'll ask her if
she really agrees but let's let's not
delay and let's get to the thing that I
think most people will be having on
their minds right now Winter's coming
energy uh is an issue the National Grid
says that though it's unlikely there
could be planned blackout do you agree
with that it's extremely unlikely so let
me again I I again cabinet office and my
responsibilities to chair those meetings
we've got a couple of things that that
are
um things that we've done that help us
deal with
um winter and of course war on our
continent is the cause of
um uh you know us being very focused on
making sure we have the resilience in
place over winter what have we got we've
got the second largest LNG processing
infrastructure in Europe yeah with half
of our gas we produce here at home we
want to go further this year we've
increased our output by 26 percent on
gas we've got interconnectors with our
neighbors now what the National Grid is
saying is the extremely unlikely
scenario where there's issues in Europe
with the interconnectors
um and the cold snap very important snap
so but it's possible isn't it so it is
extremely unlikely but it's only right
that we you know plan for every scenario
but all I would say is we have a buffer
the same buffer as last year and so I'm
confident that come Christmas come you
know the cold weather we will continue
to be in that resilient place but it's
only right that we have
um you know we have actually looked at
every scenario okay now what the
National Grid is doing with off gem is
also actually you know having a a
communication
program to tell people how they can do
better we ourselves UK you will be able
to see
um how you can actually uh you know this
is interesting your home or your
business conserve energy because this is
very interesting so so the the the the
stories we've been hearing about the
government saying to uh Jacob response
Department that plan that you've got for
telling people how they can dial down
the amount of energy that they use there
will now be a government campaign and
government not Direction but uh
government information about how we can
all use less energy so
the the question you ask is about
spending 14 million pounds on a campaign
that I think is the wrong thing because
actually
um if you go on gov dot UK now you'll
see
um if you search how you know what tips
there are for you to be able to
um conserve more energy use energy
wisely the National Grid and off Gem and
actually a number of the energy
providers are using the direct
communication with households uh to be
able to say you know here are some
measures that you can take okay tell us
things like how we turn down the boiler
temperature is it going to tell us what
we what do laundry we're not doing is
spending 14 million pounds on a
government campaign yeah okay you don't
have to spend money but um well let me
ask you you know you're the minister for
sorting stuff out really at the moment
um if I say to you what should I be
doing should I be doing my laundry at
night should I the Norwegians are
telling people shower with a friend uh
is that um is that what you're going to
be recommending so I think look the the
really positive thing that list trust
has done if you think through what she
did in the first two days is having that
energy price cap where the average
household will not pay more than two and
a half thousand pounds has two positive
things about that right
we haven't got all day I just want to
ask you it helps you be giving people
advice about things they ought to do to
re uh reduce the amount of energy they
personally use and we collectively so if
they go on gov dot UK there's lots of
advice on that
um and that naturally specifically no
not a specific campaign but actually the
bearing down on the cost of energy for
households help people cope
um with war on our continent
um and make sure they have a safe
Christmas when it comes to their energy
consumption by the way there's one other
thing which we haven't talked about it
actually Bears down on inflation up to
five percent on inflation and that
fiscal responsibility will help then the
monetary policy that is the Independent
Bank of England be hopefully bring
inflation back under control as well we
are seeing this morning images of uh at
least one half of a bridge between
Russia and Crimea in the water
and as you've already suggested that is
part of the problem that we're facing to
do with energy and Foods uh shortages
potentially and so on
is this a turning point in that war do
you think
so when I was translating this Checker I
worked with Janet Yellen my opposite
number two in the united states in the
United States to get the political
agreement at G7 on the oil price cap so
that we don't allow Putin to profiteer
from excessively high prices of oil
um I think Mr Putin needs to end this
war and the way you end this war is by
actually pulling your troops from all of
the Ukraine as quickly as possible we
will continue to support the ukrainians
in their incredible Endeavor to get
their country uh back Ben Wallace spoke
about this at Party Conference the work
that he is doing that James cleverley is
doing at the department in development
and of course Aid that's going into uh
Ukraine uh it will continue
um and I think there's one way to stop
this war the only way to stop this war
is for Russia to withdraw from Ukraine
well that's not necessarily the case Mr
Putin thinks we understand that there
may be another way to stop this at War
which is the use of nuclear weapons and
Mr Biden has said that they think that's
a reality realistic Prospect Mr
zielinski has said he thinks that's a
realistic Prospect does the British
government think that it's a realistic
prospect that Putin could use nuclear
weapons well British is unpredictable
and I will not
um wish to speculate as to
um what he does next the right thing to
do is to withdraw I think the Russian
people will have something to say if he
decides to give the order to use nuclear
weapons on people that he claims to be
his
um cousins and yeah I haven't had much
family so far have they I mean but the
main point I really want to ask you is a
year ago we didn't take what he said
seriously and we didn't we were
surprised frankly by February 24th it's
quite the opposite if you remember
Trevor we were actually front running
that story which irritated him we with
our allies the Americans we were telling
the world that Putin will invade he's
preparing for Invasion uh full-scale
Invasion when actually few people okay
in other parts of the world
um agreed with us
I wouldn't argue the toss with you about
that but if we are so uh if we know it
all what do we actually believe he is
likely to to do now will he or will he
not according to the briefings and
advice that you have be prepared to use
nuclear weapons we don't know it all we
have to continue to support the
ukrainians
um and of course they have to be the
ones in the lead on this
um they're the ones who are fighting for
their freedom fighting for our freedom
um you know if you go back a step Trevor
because you you you this is important to
you if you remember what Putin did with
Assad in Syria where there was that red
line about using chemical weapons and we
never actually followed through because
actually it was Ed miliband at the time
his little Live party he would draw
support to Cameron on that he then took
the Crimea and there was very little
impact now
um it is very different now Europe the
world's United in many ways the free
world's United in supporting Ukraine to
claim their freedom and our freedom and
safety back
thank you very much for your time this
morning thank you
now if these are difficult times for the
new government then labor might feel
they're hitting New Heights
some opinion polls are giving them a
30-point lead over the conservatives
an election has to be called in the next
two years so how is the party going to
win that power and while they might
criticize the government undoubtedly
will they must now convince voters that
they can solve the cost of living crisis
to see what they're going to do I'm
joined by the shadow work and pensions
secretary Jonathan Ashworth good morning
um
Adam zahal he's just been saying uh what
is Labor's view about
Putin's intentions we we can't know he's
right to say that Britain is
unpredictable but do you think we need
to be prepared for the possibility that
he could use nuclear weapons well of
course we have to be prepared for all
eventualities that I'm not going to
speculate on the on the mind of uh of
Putin I'm not remotely in a position to
do so but clearly
we need to consider continue to support
Ukraine in every way that we can we need
to work internationally to ensure that
pressure is continually applied uh to
Putin's to Putin and of course yes we
have to be prepared but look I I I've
heard I've read uh expert suggest that
this may be a bluff I mean it's pretty
serious I'm not I'm not downplaying it
remotely but it's not for me to
speculate on the on the psychology of
computing and what he may or may not do
but obviously we need to be prepared all
right let's let's deal with psychology
at home I know you study um
labor has said that it would not have
proposed the abolition 45p rate
um labor has said that it will keep the
1p of income tax if it comes to power it
will also keep the cap on energy bills
and spend 2 billion pounds on NHS staff
you also support the Investments
proposed by the Tories and skills on
what they call supply side
um
other than the windfall tax what
concrete measures would a labor
government take to deal with the
economic situation that the
conservatives have not taken well the
economic situation is perilous at the
moment because that budget three weeks
ago or so wasn't just a budget which
gave 45 billion pounds worth of unfunded
tax cuts disproportionately to the
better off in society because there was
no validation of the plans of that
budget by the independent obr it led to
turmoil on the markets it led to guilt
yields Rising it led to a run on Pension
funds and now mortgage costs are soaring
so people coming off off a mortgage and
this year about 1.8 million of them will
be doing that in the next 12 months or
so are facing Emoji mortgage increase of
hundreds of pounds every every month as
a consequence so we are in a particular
perilous moment because of decisions
that were taken by Liz truss and quasi
quattang three weeks ago it's why we've
called for that kamikaze to budget to be
reversed because we need to build a
dynamic economy absolutely but we need
stability in our economy instead what
we've got is a reckless approach a spike
in borrowing costs and now the
government as we understand it are
talking about asking working mums and
dads disabled people poorer pensioners
to pay the price for that recklessness
if I may say so um Sky viewers know all
of that because we're reporting it all
the time what Skies viewers have no idea
about is what you would do so let me ask
you again what would labor do other than
the windfall tax which would only last a
year what would labor do to tackle all
the problems you've enumerated that the
conservatives are not now doing well
actually our party conference just two
weeks ago we outlined how we're going to
rebuild our economy make our economy
more Dynamic and spread prosperity and
opportunity for example we're going to
invest in the green technologies of the
future not only because well they're not
the problem is they're not are they if
they were
a gas storage facilities they've
criticized solar panels in fields I mean
I remember they were refusing to go for
off onshore wind so they're not invested
in the green technology in the future
they're not refusing to go for offshore
onshore onshore they haven't made a
decision no no come on no no no no no
you asked me a question I'm going to
give you another 30 seconds
30 seconds no I don't want to tell us
how bad the tour is I'm not talking
about the Tories I'm talking about what
labor are doing we're going to invest in
these green technologies not only
because that because in this period of
international instability how much are
you going to invest 28 billion pounds
okay you know Rachel Reeves told us that
uh she told me that actually about six
months ago okay so what's new about the
cost of living about inflation we're not
in a different situation you yourself
have just said that what would would you
do about this situation that Tories
don't do I tell you what we will do
we're going to reform our welfare system
to get people back to work the 600 000
over 50s have left the labor market
since the Pandemic those leaving the
labor market for reasons of sickness is
now rising at its highest rate ever and
is at a 20-year high and yet we don't
have a job center plus system or a
welfare system that is supporting these
people to go back into work many of them
say they will return to work if they're
given the correct support to do it and
yet the government are not giving those
people any support whatsoever now if you
can get people back to work that is a
supply side reform what does that
support look like what is it is it money
well is it advice what is it well some
of it is to do with advice and
employment services so for example if if
you're in your 50s and you've left the
labor market it may be that you are
looking for a flexible type of work it
may be that you're caring for
grandchildren but also caring for a
loved one a mum or a dad or a partner he
might have that Dementia or might have
had a stroke and you're looking for a
flexible work option at the moment you
can't walk into the job center and ask
for help to find that job for you so I
want to reform the way job sensors work
I want to reform the way in which we do
Employment Services in this country to
get more people into work and those who
are currently on benefits in low paid
work I want to give them the help so
they can work more hours or move into
better paid jobs so actually we've got a
big program of Reform to our social
security system which will help more
people into work which is the type of
supply side reform that will actually
bring inflation down stabilize the cost
of living and grow our economy all right
look I mean we could carry on about that
I'm not sure I can still quite see the
difference here but let's talk there's a
big difference because the conservative
government aren't doing that okay and
there's a million vacancies in the
economy all I can tell you is that they
will sit here and tell me that they are
doing it but they won't I promise you
they won't I absolutely
let's talk about something that is that
matters today and that is the s p have
their conference we are pretty sure that
they will um call for a second
independent referendum if labor were in
government would it Grant the SNP a
second referendum no okay uh the
Scottish government let me ask you
another thing because
it it's it is thought unlikely that uh
that labor will get an outright majority
that are looking at the polls today
that's possible but let's just see let's
say uh that the most like outcome here
is that labor would need some support
from the SNP
um what are your relations like right
now on issues like for example the
gender recognition question uh the Scott
Scottish national party says that it
plans to make it legal for an individual
born with a typical male body to have
their gender change without any
professional assessment or medical
intervention
um that's what they want to do will
labor support that bill well hang on the
whole premise of your question was that
labor cannot form a majority now I'm not
one to pray in a opinion polls because I
believe the only opinion polls that
matter is the one on elections you told
me that before on Election Day but
um I'm afraid
um the premise of your question is that
labor won't get majority well the
opinion polls are not showing that at
the moment as indeed you did concede
when you asked me the question
so look look right we are planning we
are campaigning for and we are hoping to
win the trust of the British people to
form a majority labor government so
whatever the SMP policy is here or there
or everywhere is around relevant we're
going to form a majority labor
government in order to rebuild our
public services in order to get people
back to work and actually to support
people from this cost of living to come
back to my specific question will the
Labor uh party in these Scottish
Parliament vote for this piece of
legislation
I mean I presume the the I mean I don't
know is the honest answer but I presume
my colleagues in the Scottish labor
party uh uh are broadly supportive of uh
uh of changes to support trans people
who are a very marginalized group in
society are very stigmatized weapon
society and have uh are often treated
but including male bodied people going
into women's refuges for example and
women's prisons well is that a specific
that's what the item is my colleagues in
the Scottish labor party in the
parliament will no doubt have opinions
on this and we'll we'll respond I mean
I'm not a member of the Scottish
Parliament all right John Ashworth thank
you very much indeed for your time this
morning
now this week the Supreme Court will
hear one of the biggest and most
sensitive constitutional arguments
should Scotland be allowed to hold a
second Independence referendum the
current rules mean it can only take
place if the UK government agrees to a
vote as I've just been talking to
Jonathan Ashworth about the SNP
government in Hollywood argues that
having won last year's Scottish
parliamentary election they have the
right to call another ballot well the
opinion polls on the question of
Scottish independence remained very
finely balanced so with the cost of
living crisis can the SNP persuade Scots
to their cause
we're joined by Angus Robertson from the
s p cabinet secretary for the
Constitution external Affairs and
culture in Scotland good morning Mr
Robertson
morning Trevor thank you for joining us
now Nicola sturgeons complained this
week that Liz trust hasn't been in touch
um is that still true
I believe so yeah
and um just as a matter of interest uh
why doesn't she just pick up the phone
and call Liz Truss
well I think the first Minister did
speak in passing to Liz truss at the
funeral for her majesty at the queen but
it's common custom and practice when
somebody takes up office this is what
happened with
um both Boris Johnson and uh his
predecessor that they got in touch with
the first Ministers of both Scotland and
Wales on assuming office within days of
doing so that's what happened then
that's not what's happening now and it's
disappointing and frankly a bit childish
well yeah but you know Nicholas
surgeon's been there a lot longer than
Liz truss
um wouldn't it be a bit grown up for her
to she knows Liz trust just ring up and
say um when are we going to have a chat
I just told you that she did speak to
her
um what it is is the issue is that the
Prime Minister who if you remember made
great play of suggesting that she would
ignore the first minister of Scotland is
ignoring the first minister of Scotland
is ignoring the first minister of Wales
and that's not supposed to how it's
supposed to work okay a multinational
State we're supposed to have grown-up
relations uh which is exactly why the
first Minister did speak to the new
prime minister at the Queen's funeral
unfortunately the Prime Minister hasn't
found time yet to speak to the first
Ministers of Scotland or Wales since
assuming office had time to speak to a
lot of other people
okay this is uh forgive me this might be
a little confusing for viewers she has
spoken to her or she has not spoken to
her what what would you have they spoken
or have they spoken to the
the first minister of Scotland spoken
passing to the prime minister at the
funeral of her majesty the queen that's
what I said a moment ago what's normal
when a prime minister takes office is
that they call
um the leaders of governments and
countries with whom they have a valued
relationship that's the normal custom
and practice and the prime minister of
the United Kingdom has not seen fit to
speak to the first Ministers of Scotland
or Wales at any great length since
taking office which is odd given that a
unionist a unionist politician who says
that the respect agenda between the UK
government and the different nations of
the United Kingdom it doesn't think that
it's we're speaking to the leaders of
Scotland or Wales okay I okay I I
understand the point is that uh uh Miss
sturgeon feels she hasn't been spoken to
with at the right time and with
sufficient respect and uh at same length
now one of the things that they could
have talked about then would have been
uh the state of the economy and what you
do about it together
um can you just make clear what what is
the Scottish government's point of view
on the basic rate of income tax will it
be uh agreeing with the UK government
that the basic rate should come down to
19
P which is uh in the Scottish
government's purview you can decide
whether it goes with it or doesn't what
what are you going to do
so the first so the the first thing that
the Scottish government would do is tell
the UK government that it has made a
huge mistake with its approach to the UK
economy crashing the currency driving
debt through the roof
um leading to uncertainty in the markets
that is driving mortgage rates up which
will make mortgage payments of far too
many people length and breadth of the UK
unaffordable so
um launching a Kamikaze budget at the
beginning of a term of office is
certainly not something that the SNP
would be supporting and from the start
we have said that especially in relation
to the tax cuts to the rich whether it's
the 45p rate or whether it's the bankers
bonuses and that's exactly the wrong way
to go in terms of other tax changes
Deputy first Minister John Swinney um
has called together experts who will be
advising him with a report before the
end of this month when we have to make
decisions about what we will be doing
with tax rates in Scotland you're
absolutely right to highlight that we do
have we do have marginal um controls
over taxation in Scotland and at that
point the right decisions would be made
but we would certainly not have been
emulating and the Very damaging approach
that the UK Tory government has been
making uh towards the economy in
Scotland and the rest of the UK
so if you if your view is that you do
not want to copy what um uh the trust
government is doing it is quite possible
that um come April Scots will be paying
more in income tax than everybody else
in the UK
I'm sure you'd want to finish off that
sentence by pointing out the fact of
yours in the rest of the UK that
taxpayers in Scotland in general the
majority pay less tax across the piece
than the rest of the United Kingdom
those are the factors they stand we are
trying to find the appropriate balance
in government policy to no no no no no
no no no no
sorry
just okay let me sorry sorry you didn't
you didn't clarify you didn't I'm sorry
you've responded on the total tax tag
the question I really I asked was that
the individual in Scotland would be
paying a higher basic rate than others
in the UK
and I as I said and I'm not incorrect to
point this out the majority of taxpayers
in Scotland pay less tax than the rest
of the United Kingdom that is the
context at the present time I also said
just a moment ago that Deputy first
Minister John Sweeney who's in in charge
of the public finances at this present
time in Scotland is reviewing the impact
of the UK government's
um mini budget to work out what the
appropriate decisions should be in
Scotland and would we do it on the basis
of the facts unlike the UK government
that has been making very damaging
decisions without the advice of the
office of budget responsibility we are
going to make decisions about Scotland's
finances in a prudent way but there's a
wide-appointed issue with this Trevor
which is Scotland doesn't need to be in
this situation we don't need to have our
public finances decided upon by people
that we have not elected since 1955. we
of course have another option and we
voted in favor of that in last year's
Scottish Parliament election name namely
to have a referendum in this country so
that we can become an independent state
and rejoin the European Union I would
far rather not be at the mercy of Tory
chancellors of the exchequer or prime
ministers who we haven't voted for it's
not sustainable and it's not sensible
given everything that we've learned
about their financial imprudence and
their belief in a thatcherite economic
Orthodoxy which is going to cost us all
dearly all right let's move away from
the things that um for which as you
would put it the Tories are responsible
and let's talk about the things which
you do all by yourself so for example
um they're supposed to be an inquiry
into covid in Scotland can you tell us
when that's going to start and by the
way can you tell us why the chair and I
think three
um Junior count three four councils uh
have resigned from that inquiry
so in in Scotland we have a separation
of powers government is separate from
the legal system so it's not for me to
speak on behalf of
um Scottish judges or Scottish Advocates
about an inquiry that is separate from
government you'll have to arrange to
speak to people in Scotland's legal
system for those kind of questions we
value the separation of government and
our judicial system and it's going to
remain that way
uh Professor Peter Watson who represents
the families of those who lost uh loved
ones says
this inquiry is going nowhere it's
commissioned by the Scottish government
uh surely you do have some
responsibility for it
well I I would wish it could be underway
and I would wish that it would report as
quickly as possible the lessons need to
be learned and as you quite rightly say
families wants answers they deserve that
I'm pointing out a big basic fact about
the the way government and the way our
judicial system works in in this country
it's not for us to intervene in
Personnel decisions about independent
legal inquiries of course I I I hope
that it is up and running as quickly as
possible I hope that it can conclude as
quickly as possible and it's a shame
that things are not underway those
questions though are rightly to be
addressed um at our legal authorities
who are very separate from government
and quite rightly so and in the meantime
if there's any way that government can
help whilst from protecting the
independence of our our legal system and
get to get on with the inquiry that we
would all want to see conclude we would
be happy to do that all right well let's
try and talk about something for which
you and only you are responsible which
is what you say about Indie ref two the
the first Minister said this week that
if you don't get a favorable judgment
from the Supreme Court that you will
treat the general election as a vote on
Independent now some people might say
that's just a tad arrogant isn't it for
the voters to decide what a general
election is about
well let's just remind ourselves what
the voters actually decided and we had
an election last year where this was the
number one issue in the election people
voted and they voted in record numbers
for a pro-independence government in the
Scottish Parliament at the parties that
were elected on a Manifesto com
commitment that the people should be
able to decide in the referendum won the
election and the parties that oppose
that the concern with
respects
greatest Trevor you were a voting how do
you know that that was the number one
issue for that the Great
with the greatest well I I was in the
middle of the election campaign I had
the Good Fortune to win the seat uh that
Ruth Davidson previously held as the
leader of the Scottish conservative
party in Edinburgh Central I know very
well why I won that election I know what
was in my Manifesto and the people not
knew what was in the SNP manifest I'm
not going to patronize the electorate
the electorate uh voted for a
pro-independence majority in the
Parliament and to Simply do as if that
doesn't matter
um frankly it's not good enough in in a
democracy and when you have guests on
programs and ask them whether they will
respect democratic election results to
Simply pass on from it when they they
say no we're not going to respect a
democracy is frankly slightly odd in my
view it is remarkable how UK political
parties that lost the election Scotland
in this issue are given a pass on this
either we live in a democracy or we
don't the people have voted to have the
right to choose and in a democracy the
people should be able to choose they can
vote Yes they can vote no but surely
they should have the right to choose we
can solve this issue very simply because
we managed to do it in the run-up to
2014 the UK government respected the
election result in Scotland they passed
what was called a section 30 order and
we were able to hold a referendum in
Scotland there is no impediment to this
happening the fact that we've had to go
to the Supreme Court the fact that we're
having to invoke the possibility of
using elections to yet again show that
people want to choose on this country's
future is not where we need to be at far
rather the UK government just respected
the Scottish electorate respected the um
the election result and the majority of
the Scottish Parliament and as good
Democrats as Democrats abide by
Democratic standards unfortunately the
conservatives and now sadly also the
labor party are perfectly happy to
discard Scottish democracy and it's not
good enough okay Angus Robertson thank
you so much for for joining us this
morning
thank you for having me
Now train Services across the country
are returning to normal this morning but
already other key workers are
threatening widespread strike action
the Royal College of Nursing has sent
ballot papers to 300 000 members across
the UK the largest vote it's ever called
the college says that nurses are
understaffed undervalued and underpaid
with us this morning is Pat Cullen the
rcn's general secretary and chief
executive good morning thanks for
joining us
um
before we talk about the strike wherever
you actually where have you actually got
to the negotiations
um well
pretty simply and we aren't in
negotiations I have made many attempts
on behalf of not just the 300 000 nurses
that have been balloted but the 500 000
plus nurses that I represent and
unfortunately this government hasn't
engaged with the Royal College of
Nursing as yet when you say they have
engaged and and uh do you mean that
you've asked for a meeting and um
whoever happened to be Health secretary
at the time said no I'm not talking to
you well the last Health secretary that
I'd contact with was Sergeant Javad and
since then we have made multiple
attempts to try and engage with the
health secretary and the two the current
one and the previous one that was very
short lived and both of those people
have not as yet met with the Royal
College of Nursing but presumably the
the actual employer here anyway is not
to read coffee is no the health
secretary but the NHS presumably you are
talking to NS NHS managers of course
we're talking about and where have you
got to with them well of course the NHS
managers will say very clearly to me
that it's not within their gift to
um negotiate with me on pay for their
employees which are our nurses so I'm
bounced back to government and that's
right that's absolutely right those
employers do not have the authority uh
to actually negotiate because agenda for
change sits at um which is the pay
framework for our nursing staff sits
within the domain of government to make
those decisions
what um what is it that you want
um what what is your sales's central
demand well first of all for nurses to
be paid a fair and decent wage that's
what we're asking for and our ask is
five percent above the rate of inflation
that's very clear it's not about nurses
um being greedy
it's not about wanting the same
um preferential treatment that was given
to the bankers and others by this
government we're asking for them to be
paid a fair and decent wage so that we
can retain them in the Health Service
looking after our passions well
um let's leave the bankers aside because
they're not paid by the government
they're not paid by the taxpayer five
percent above inflation this morning is
14.9 percent
that's quite a hefty rise
well Trevor you did mention the bankers
but if you looked and um of course we
attended the Conservative Party
Conference and we listened very
carefully to what they say and it does
seem that those people like bankers and
others are very carefully looked after
what we have seen very clearly from this
government is that they haven't managed
to actually recognize that they cannot
have a Health Service without nurses we
heard this morning from ministers coming
on this program and talking about how
they're going to deliver on their as
their base their says and their days and
what I want to say to each and every one
of them they'll deliver on none of those
if they do not understand there's an n
in the alphabet because each one of
those depend on nurses we deliver
nothing in Health and Social care
without having a nurse and yet they have
just seemed to not understand that they
need to understand that there's a nen in
the alphabet and they need to respect
nurses if they want to retain them in
the Health Service if we can stop our
nurses having to leave the Health
Service and indeed social care to find
jobs in supermarkets in restaurants and
other places that they can pay their
bills I think that's an incredible
indictment on any minister to sit here
and not actually recognize what they are
doing to the Health Service and to
patients do you um are you getting any
more mileage if I can put it that way
from the devolved administration's
Scotland is a separate negotiation I I
guess as it would be Northern Ireland
well certainly in Scotland there was a
higher percentage and pay award
um granted this time right it certainly
didn't come anywhere near a what nurses
require in order to make a decent living
and this isn't they're not asking for
um as I've said golden handshakes out of
this or not they're asking for a decent
living wage and they're not getting that
so no government and of course we know
the situation in Northern Ireland so
we'll not go there but as yet none of
the default administrations have come up
to the standard that we expect them to
for our nursing staff so you'll be going
back to the Scots and Stormont when when
there is a government installment and
saying that nurses need a bit more we've
already done that yes and of course in
those three hundred thousand ballot
papers that went out they went out right
across the UK not just in England well
let's talk about what that means
um we don't have any experience of a
nurse's strike how would that work I
mean what if you walk out
what happens to
patients who are
in intensive care patients who are going
to be dehydrated patients who need their
dressings changed okay well actually we
do have experience of a nurse's strike
and I had the privilege but actually the
sadness of leading the first nurses
strike in 103 years history of this
college in late
2019-2020 in Northern Ireland when we
actually had no government
um and during that time what I would say
to each person and member of the public
listening this morning our nursing staff
and I am a nurse of 42 years will never
walk away from you and during that
strike in Northern Ireland we did not
walk out on our passions we made sure
our patients were still cared for now of
course there will be disruption because
the clue is in the title it is about
withdrawal of labor but we still
continue to provide a life preserving
Services during that time and there are
certain services that we will absolutely
never withdraw labor from but what
action would you say because if I may
put it straight you can't have it both
ways you can't say that we are going to
hold the government's feet to the fire
but actually if it becomes difficult for
anybody we're going to look after them
well there's life preserving services
that we will always continue to provide
because we are a regulated profession we
will absolutely not just down tools and
leave our patients and abandon them we
haven't done it to date and we'll not do
it now we certainly will not and but
there will be a withdrawal of nursing
staff and we have very clear clinical
protocols in place about how we manage
that on a day of a strike about the
number of staff that will remain to
provide services for our patients and
those that will then obviously that you
will see should the time come and that
will be seen on picket lines and that
will be managed very carefully and very
safely and the other thing that I will
say that during the strike in Northern
Ireland which lasted for eight days and
again if our nurse's ballot and for
strike action in any of our UK countries
as we move forward in November we will
cause no further or additional risk to
patients that's already created as a
consequence of this government turning
their back on nursing as we be stamped
well if I mean can we be specific about
the
World midwives for example be involved
in this action in Northern Ireland we
certainly didn't withdraw midwives
um at the time of our strike action no
we didn't and the nurses with ambulances
waiting three four five six seven eight
and yes and I go back to the point that
I made in the a the B the C and the d
none of those will be will will be
delivered absolutely not and why do we
see those ambulances queued up at the
minute we see them queued up because
there's not the nursing staff to look
after those passions that are in the
backs of those ambulances and what an
indictment on a society to actually keep
patients our elderly patients in the
backs of ambulance simply because we
have turned our back on nursing staff
and finally if I may ask briefly what
will you do if the government says we're
going to treat nurses like police
officers and make it unlawful for them
to strike
well we heard a lot this morning about
democracy didn't we and this is the
Democratic right of the worker to
actually first of all belong to a Trade
union and then have representation and
why are we representing our nurses
because there's no government speaking
up for them at the minute and again that
would be another nail in the coffin for
this government to say that they're
actually going to silence the workers
the people at the front line the
clinical staff looking after patients
day in Daily so I think that would be a
very sad day if we move to that position
and certainly our Royal College of
Nursing will have something to say about
it pat Garland thank you very much
indeed thank you
no some of Britain's leading
supermarkets are stepping in to help
staff and customers cope with the cost
of living crisis
Sainsbury's offering its staff extra pay
Rises and free food Asda has gone even
further selling anyone over 60 a bowl of
soup a roll and unlimited tea and coffee
for just one pound in its cafes in
November and December I'm ready so our
supermarkets the right people to help
the poorest in society cope this winter
we're joined by the former chief
executive of Sainsbury's Justin King
good morning Justin
good morning Trevor and I'm one of those
over 60s too so yeah
yeah I'll I'll see you down there
um
look we're saying supermarkets taking
these actions special deals explicitly
aimed uh at people to help people in
tough economic circumstances
um
one as the I think it is providing warm
spaces for people
do you support all of that
well I've worked for Asda Sainsbury's
I'm a director of marks and Spencer's
now and uh it's been my working life so
yes I do I think supermarkets have
always taken very seriously the role
that they play in helping their
customers if you like make ends meet and
the challenge hasn't been as great as
this until uh well since you and I were
a lot younger I can remember the 1970s
which is probably the last time the
challenges households were as great
um and they will play what part they can
you have to remember of course
supermarkets typically make uh only
about three percent profit so you know
even if they invested say half of their
uh potential profits in this kind of
activity it's only going to make a small
dent but an important dent I would
suggest on the challenges of you know
nearly 10 inflation that you've just
been discussing
but I I suppose a question that will
occur to many people is whether this is
really a supermarket business let me put
it uh This Way
um
the big shareholders in most British
supermarkets uh chains are also for
example Pension funds and they expect a
return is it really right for
supermarkets to be doing a job that
really is for the Social Services uh and
endangering the returns uh for
pensioners
well I said they're playing their part
and of course what they're really doing
is competing they're fighting for
customers you know when times are
challenging uh customers do shop around
a bit more so
um if you wanted to be cynical of course
you could say that these are just
marketing activities aimed at capturing
new customers so I don't see any kind of
logical disconnect if you like between
this kind of activity and supermarkets
doing the right thing for their
shareholders too of course only uh two
of our supermarkets are now uh publicly
listed companies the big ones uh anyway
Sainsbury's in Tesco others are
privately held or held by uh big
worldwide chains
um I frankly don't think you should
worry too much at any customers to worry
too much about shareholders being looked
after that's the job of management along
with making sure they do a great job for
customers because in the long run the
right thing for shareholders is doing
the right thing for customers
okay well I I suppose that I read the
earlier this week that um waitrose has
its thermal underwear flying off the
shelves and uh I suppose some people
might wonder whether the real answer
here is for supermarkets to be pricing
their uh normal Goods even more
competitively because that will help a
wider range of people rather than what
to some people might look like a bit of
a gimmick
well as I said you know the cynical
might say it's just a marketing activity
but it doesn't mean it's a bad thing to
do uh yes of course across the piece
they'll need to keep their prices sharp
if you're not competitive on price at
the moment and more and more customers
are focusing on price then you're going
to be in trouble competitively so I
think they'll be doing that too but as I
said that earlier you know they haven't
got massive profit percentages they can
make a dent uh in the inflation that
customers will experience on their
grocery shop and you mentioned waitrose
and thermals a battle Being John Lewis
and of course marks and Spencer has a
big clothing business to keeping clothes
competitive particularly those we use to
wrap up warm as we enter winter that'll
be part of the competition too
is there a danger here though I mean
this is all this all sounds
whether it's marketing gimmick or not
it's going to benefit some people I
don't think anybody will object to that
but there is a danger that What's
Happening Here is that the government
gets uh LED off the hook uh because next
week a minister will come in here and
say to Sophie honestly you know don't
expect us to do too much uh and
everybody's pitching in look at what the
supermarket's doing they're helping
well I have a chat with Sophie and tell
her not to let them off that hook
obviously everyone should play their
part and supermarkets will do because
it's a competitive market but you spend
most of this program discussing one way
or another uh what difference the
government can make uh we've seen on
Energy prices a very significant and
costly uh support package but we should
remember every single pound the
government spends is our money still
we'll have to pay it back through taxes
or perhaps more likely our children and
grandchildren will be paying it back
through taxes so I don't think either we
should be uh overly blase about the
amount of money the government's
spending personally I think it should be
more targeted and less blanket I think
those of us that can afford and I'm very
fortunate to be one of those people to
pay my bills for the energy even at
these higher levels I think we should
pay off all bills and that would leave
more money for the most needing and I
personally believe
um much government activity would be
better if it were targeted
does that mean um I mean you you've been
in charge of some of the biggest
Enterprises in this country with
millions of consumers and so on uh so
you do follow their behaviors pretty
closely
um
from that point of view do you think
that what the chancellor did and the way
he approached the issue of dealing with
cost of living
um was essentially the wrong approach
from what you've just said about
targeting it suggests that you think
that uh
they could have done better
well look the I think we now officially
call it a mini uh budget was uh argued
to be necessary because the issues that
addressed were urgent and some of those
issues uh fuel prices for winter were
clearly urgent but others of the issues
some of the tax changes you've been
discussing were not urgent and I think
that's as much as anything is what uh
spurred the markets with the
consequences that it's going to have for
people's household budgets with
inflation and interest rates of course
um but yeah so it's a general rule I
don't think the government should be
giving money to those uh people who can
afford to pay their bills so it can give
more money to those who are going to
struggle I think targeting is perfectly
possible initially through the benefit
system but through some kinds of means
testing and I also they should think
there should be a limit to the help the
government provides um you know long
before this cost of living crisis
arrived we were discussing uh the carbon
crisis and a higher energy prices higher
fuel prices we're all driving our cars
less because of how expensive petrol and
Diesel is that's a good thing if you
take the Long View it may be painful to
household budgets in the short term but
we have to have a different relationship
with energy we as a society so I I would
not provide an unlimited support I would
make sure that everyone's able to keep
themselves warm and fed But ultimately
we have to pay a higher price for Energy
going forward
admirably clear as always Justin thanks
very much for joining us this this
morning
thank you
well that's it uh for this week's Sophie
Ridge on Sunday it's been fun to be back
here only for one morning after the
break we'll run through today's
interviews and see what we've learned
and I'll be joined by a political
correspondent Rob Powell for the take
thanks for joining us this Sunday
morning stay with us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]